cringe jump here said dangerous to say
transgender kids can hurt girls in
sports you know when logic and this is
the press secretary because if she says
it you know it's right so here's a
couple things that's going on in
different states another state just
banned transgender athletes from women's
college sports this is a town hall story
it's on page 15 if you want to go to it
so uh uh Texas governor Albert signed
the the safe women's sports act which
prohibits transgender women from
participating in women's college sports
Governor Abbott stated women's sports
are being threatened some women are
being forced to compete against
biological men Alabama Governor K Ivy
also signed legislation Banning male
bodied athletes from competing in
women's sports emphasize fairness if
your biological male you are not going
to be competing in women's and girls
Sports in Alabama Republican state uh
representative Susan Dubose the sponsor
of the bill highlighted the inherent
advantage of being born male no amount
of hormone therapy can undo all those
advantages instances like transgender
swimmer Leah Thomas winning against
female athletes have sparked concerns
about fairness and equal opportunities
Tom you got two girls when you read this
story and you're seeing what you know
Governor Abbott did we lived in Texas
for five six years what are your
thoughts when you see this story here
well first of all Constantine thank you
for your comments because I agree with
you I believe trans is about to break a
lot of uh the the will of a lot of the
resistance here is is not going away and
what I've been watching with with my
girls is a simple truth you can when you
just said Abracadabra Stacy there is no
time there is no test and there is no
validation required all I have to do on
a Monday and said I'm no longer Thomas
I'm Thomasina I will now be playing with
the girls Golf and I declare it that's a
so in sports when you allow that
emotional Declaration of who I feel I am
going back to what you're talking about
liberalism is based on feelings I feel
I'm a female now I'm allowed to go
compete and we've seen the outcome of
that a six foot three man still with
male genitalia as was seen by all the
women that were in the locker room at
the Ivy League championships I said wait
a minute they said he was a girl that
there
that's male genitalia hanging off this
guy and number one and number two he's
six three and he had size 13 feet those
are much bigger flippers than the
average the average woman is going to
have picture a shocking time exactly if
that picture says a thousand words
take a look at the cowboy hat in her
expression be glad she's not armed
ladies and gentlemen because that's an
angry cowgirl there yeah so the first
thing is you have to take out of this
there's no time there's no validation
there's no test it's an emotional thing
and so you need to protect them this is
swimming showed the performance now the
risk was showed up in October of 2022 in
Cherokee County in North Carolina where
the volleyball Spike knocked the girl
unconscious and she was having
concussion system symptoms for three
weeks CAT scans proved it and then what
used to be a fairly liberal School Board
they voted 5-1 and said yeah after we
saw that volleyball Spike maybe you
can't declare a Monday you're a female
Common Sense prevails Common Sense
Prevail because they saw what happened
there well and have you played this clip
go ahead and play the clip see whatever
you got a concussion here watch watch
the lower right they should highlight
girl
watch this here she comes that's that's
the guy that's a male jumping boom she's
out she's done that's it
and so the school board saw this and
goes how long is the girl over there
nine weeks apparently she declared she
was female nine weeks and she's playing
and that's what Leah Thomas said I want
to win a championship so I declare it I
support and applaud a guy that I grew up
as a as a wannabe middle distance Runner
ran cross country and there was guys
like John Walker of New Zealand and
Steve ovet and Sebastian Co of the UK
were some of my my heroes Sebastian code
today is president of world Athletics
and said in March of this year we need
to protect women who are women in sports
and we need to have a time test a
validation test testosterone test
genitalia if you're gonna go do this he
said really we need a division for Trans
you said that's what we need we need to
protect the women here and he was very
rational about it common sense was
prevailing and I think what you're
seeing is Governors are getting hit by
the mainstream media because they're
coming out in favor of Common Sense look
you can't declare a Monday that you're a
girl and then go win a championship on
Wednesday and get your medal right
that's that's that's wrong and we need
to protect the safety of women and
Common Sense is prevailing and I think
it's great because my daughters look at
it and say so okay so what if Once Upon
a Time John Daly was a high school
golfer and decided he wanted to be a
girl he would have won all the state
championships I said Bailey that's right
and she said how is that fair right and
let's let's just be honest with each
other at the end of the day because
nobody has the ball sorry for my friends
to say it it's the it's the tease some
of these guys that are competing
at the end of the day let's just come
out and be honest it's the trans
movement hijacked the LGB the lesbian
gay and bi movement and they completely
wiped out the feminist movement because
think about it great the point it's 100
because I know Pat I know gay people
that work here I know gay people I have
gay friends I have gay they are not
happy with this entire movement they
hijacked them well I'll see you and I'll
raise you I've probably into more trans
people than than most people a lot of
trans people are also being thrown under
this bus because this is being done not
on their behalf this is being done by
like activists a lot of trans people are
actually quite sensible they're like
look I'm not comfortable in my body I
want to live in a different way I don't
need you to pretend that I am literally
the opposite sex just just don't beat me
up and leave me alone exactly right and
I kind of feel sorry for them but I'll
make another I'll tell you a story that
will blow your mind which is kind of
relevant to this so my grandmother was
born in a gulag wow she was born in a
concentration camp
for political prisoners and one of the
things people don't know is once you're
released from these camps you would be
you would not be allowed to live within
like a hundred miles of any big city so
you'd have to live in some kind of
remote town and they all ended up
settling in these remote towns in the
middle of Siberia and the only people
that lived there were the former
prisoners of the camps a few of the
local native tribes of which there were
many and the guards from the very same
camps that the prisoners came to came
from and they would live in the same
building my grandmother's family they
lived in a landing across from another
apartment and another apartment there
was a guy who was a God okay and what
she told me is when Stalin died right
and he was exposed as having committed
all these terrible atrocities and so on
there was a Spate of suicides in this
town because these guards they all
killed themselves because they genuinely
believed they were doing the right thing
when they were beating these people and
torturing these people and that's one
you know hearing those stories from my
family that's when I really learned from
early days to get people to do something
terrible but think they're good you need
ideology and this is ideology this isn't
real this isn't Common Sense the season
people thinking about it critically this
is ideology and that's how you get to
the point where you've got massive guys
playing against little girls that's how
you get there because it's ideology
people aren't actually examining the
facts and and trying to get to the right
place they're going to news that
argument's gonna remember remember how
how confident these people when they
were saying defund the police defund the
police defund the police remember those
guys oh yeah and now they're like we
never said that yeah yeah right we never
said that and then the house how quickly
these same feminists are gonna say we
never said that yeah we never said that
because the true feminists the biggest
feminist this last week protecting women
what's Greg Abbott and Greg Abbott is
not a feminist no if the definition is
to defend women Greg Abbott sat there
and said wait a minute we're not going
to let men beat up on women this is just
not fair 20 years ago that would have
been of course we're not going to let
that happen today that argument is
losing ground because of this whole uh
nonsense that they're spewing out no you
nailed the path they the trans they
hijacked the gay movement but then they
completely wiped out the feminists where
where are all those women I'll tell you
there are some so in the UK actually the
movement against this has been
absolutely spared by feminists beheaded
by feminists and you you have people
here like Megan Murphy uh and a bunch of
others but to back to your point about
you know um defund the police this is
how strong ideology is I'll give you an
example that'll make you guys laugh you
know we don't have guns in the UK right
now a lot of knives yeah a lot but we
don't have guns and this is my point
right uh in the summer of 2020 BLM
happens we've got in central London
protesters in front of police officers
going hands up don't shoot
in front of cops you don't have guns
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]